When The Incredibles hit theaters in 2004,
it was obvious that it was destined to become
a classic.
The clever spin on a superhero family was
a massive critical success that earned two
Academy Awards and raked in well over half
a billion dollars at the box office.
You can chalk that up to a thrilling storyline,
fantastic animation, and great performances,
but it also has a lot to do with the fact
that The Incredibles is one of the smartest
and most layered takes on superheroes to ever
hit the screen.
If you haven’t watched it since you were
a kid, here are a few of the things you’ll
only notice as an adult.
The jokes for the grown-ups
Like a lot of films directed primarily at
kids, Pixar movies usually contain a little
bit of humor for the parents in the audience.
Sometimes, it’s the kind of obvious gag
that might lead to having "The Talk" a little
earlier than they expected...
… and of course, there are the scenes of
a very happy Helen Parr pulling her husband
back to bed.
Others come so fast that if you blink, you
might miss them.
In the early montage about how supers have
fallen from grace, for example, one newspaper
headline shows that a hero with X-ray vision
was using his powers to become a high-tech
peeping tom.
No wonder they got rid of all those super-creeps.
The unsung genius
Edna Mode, The Incredibles' resident fashionista
and costume designer, is a huge part of the
film, but her costumes aren’t the only super-tech
that’s used by the heroes.
In just the first few minutes, Mr. Incredible
demonstrates his car's tricked out GPS system,
auto-drive function, and its ability to transform
into a much speedier vehicle upon request.
And that’s just one car!
The thing is, they never once mention the
person who created it all, giving the Incredibles
universe its most mysterious unsung hero.
How did they get so many wonderful toys that
the rest of the world doesn’t have access
to, and what happened to them after the supers
went underground?
Syndrome has the tech, but he doesn’t seem
like the type to share, and no offense, but
there’s no way that Bob built his own flying
car.
Somebody out there deserves a little more
recognition.
Edna’s voice
With her snappy dialogue and pitch-perfect
delivery, it’s not surprising that Edna
Mode was The Incredibles' breakout character.
“No capes!”
The surprise only comes later, when you find
out that the actor behind the diminutive fashionista
was none other than writer/director Brad Bird.
Bird recorded the character's vocals while
making temporary voice tracks for the film,
and even he approached actresses like Lily
Tomlin about the part.
However, he said that the other employees
at Pixar liked his vocals enough that eventually,
they stuck.
Bird isn't the only unlikely voice actor to
wind up in the film, though.
Kari the Parr's babysitter, is played by animator
Bret Parker, production designer Lou Romano
lent his voice to Dash's teacher, and Bird's
son Nick voiced the Parr’s shocked neighbor.
“That was totally wicked!”
Elastigirl is definitely a feminist
If we’re all being honest, the real hero
of The Incredibles is Elastigirl.
She’s a good mother, a supportive wife,
and the half of her marriage that doesn’t
get duped into a secret supervillain plot.
Her iconic introduction tells us exactly why:
“Leave saving the world to the men?
I don’t think so!”
Holly Hunter, who voices Elastigirl, has credited
the character's outspoken persona to writer/director
Brad Bird, calling him a "true feminist" in
a recent interview, and that shows up in the
film.
She’s not afraid to step back into action
when she's needed, standing up as a strong
feminist role model.
Kari deserves a raise
Most kids watching The Incredibles for the
first time are probably a bit too young to
have taken on their first babysitting job,
but once you have, it's easy to see the whole
thing as a horror story starring Kari, the
Parrs’ poor, put-upon babysitter.
“Jack-Jack is fine but there's some really
weird things happening ...Jack Jack is still fine but I’m gettin’
really weirded out!”
This fidgety teen is asked to go well above
and beyond the call of duty in her time taking
care of the young Jack-Jack after the Parrs
left him behind on their mission to save the
world.
We’ve looked, and they never actually covered
spontaneous combustion in any of the Babysitter’s
Club books.
Kari may get a bit of a bad rap for giving
Jack-Jack up to Syndrome when he finally relieves
her after a stressful night, but for five
bucks an hour, you’d probably hand that
kid off to an adult, too.
At the end of the day, Kari tried her best,
and she deserves to be fully compensated for
it and get a great letter of recommendation
from Bob and Helen as well.
It skewers superhero tropes
While the Incredibles have only ever been
featured in the one big story that we see
on the screen, they feel familiar too, and
not just because they argue like real families
on road trips.
"Great.
We missed it.
You asked me how to get there and I told you.
Take a left.
That'll take me downtown.
Get in the right lane.
YELLING!"
They also have a lot of similarities to some
very famous superheroes, particularly the
Fantastic Four.
“Mr. Incredible” obviously echoes the
FF’s Mister Fantastic, - in name at least
- and a quartet featuring a big strong guy,
a stretchy hero, and an invisible girl with
force fields might seem pretty familiar to
Marvel fans, too.
Even though Dash is the odd one out in that
comparison, his super-speed and red costume
are consciously reminiscent of the Flash.
It’s not just the major characters, either:
The quick snippets of other superheroes shown
in the film also seem inspired by the classics,
including Frozone's ice powers and Gazerbeam's
Cyclops-esque laser eyes.
Of course, while it’s obvious that the creators
of The Incredibles love the superhero genre,
they’re not above poking fun at its more
ludicrous extremes, either.
All those lines about villainous monologuing
are a pretty clear shot at old-school comic
book dialogue.
“You sly dog.
You got me monologuing!”
Even more important: Edna Mode’s entire
existence is based around one of the biggest
plot holes in the history of comics.
The stylist was born after Brad Bird started
to wonder how every superhero suddenly became
an expert with the needle and thread after
getting their powers and realized that somebody
else had to be designing these flamboyant
costumes.
"You're the best of the best!"
"I know darling."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!